welcoming to yang speaks a man after my
own heart
entrepreneur congressional candidate in
florida's third district which is i want
to say gainesville adam christensen
welcome adam
hey hey how are you
adam i love your story because you are a
true startup guy
uh you started a company moved across
the country
for it uh and then you looked up at your
congressional representatives and were
like you know what like i think i might
be able to
to offer something and contribute and
then you
shocked expectations you became the
democratic nominee i think you may be
the youngest congressional candidate in
the country right now
is that right at least democratic yeah
although i turned 27 a couple days ago
so i'm gonna have to check again not
sure at this point
well you're up there in terms of uh
youthful
[Laughter]
youthful candidates uh and your opponent
is
uh someone who i think she she worked
for the
former rep who kind of made a name for
himself
by being a jackass essentially
like he he's like it's funny how these
lines intersect but uh you can go ahead
and share the story about
uh i guess both the incumbent right now
who's
who's getting out of the way and then
your opponent
yeah so um ted yoho kind of you know
kind of gave us a gift he actually put
this race on the map
he's the one that verbally assaulted aoc
on the capitol steps he's also one of
the four people who voted against making
lynching a federal crime
and he also didn't like the survivor's
bill of rights the era didn't think the
uh
what was it the um oh shoot the voting
rights act was constitutional that's
something that he didn't think
so it was like all of these things he'd
been doing for years
but nobody really saw exactly who he was
until the aoc incident
at which point people started to even
realize that gainesville existed
and so that was uh you know that's kind
of that was really where our campaign
really it was a jumping-off point
honestly it was a bunch of people that
kind of realized that
you know this is the guy who's been here
for a long time uh and
we basically need to tear down his
infrastructure uh with progressive ideas
and preferably with young people and it
really just shot off from there
now so tell us a little bit more about
the genesis of your campaign i'm sure
when you were first talking about
running people were like what
you know or or thought that that was a
lot to bite off
but you ended up inspiring a lot of
young people in a college town
uh getting a ton of energy and then
growing from there can you tell us about
how
you got started and really why you
decided to get into this race
yeah um you know one of the biggest
things for me i mean i
i always enjoyed politics like i just
enjoyed it and like i always thought you
know someday maybe i might
try to run for something but i never
really had any actual idea about it
uh and then you know tried to grow past
as you know the startup stage where
effectively you get so big and at
a certain point you have to start
offering benefits to be able to keep
growing
and a lot of startups just cannot get
over that hurdle
and so that was one of the main reasons
that caused me to jump into this was
you know i had two companies and they
both got to that hurdle and i saw a
bunch of other small ones
that got to that hurdle and they either
sold to bigger people or they just
you know petered out or they tried to
get out of it and so for me
that's when i kind of realized you know
that you know somebody needed to change
that
and at the same time i was i had looked
and saw that ted yoho was going to
retire
and so i looked and saw who the
democratic people were that were running
and i just i wasn't really impressed
and i was kind of complaining and
somebody was like well you know what you
don't really get to complain if you're
not going to do something about it
and so my response to that was okay well
how would you get on the ballot
and so then i took the puppy out we went
out and tried to get as many petitions
as we could in the farmer's market and
within about two weeks we had almost 600
different petitions that have been
signed
and then i basically started talking to
people um and i sat down at a coffee
shop with
the person who became my campaign
manager his name's anton curnahan he
just turned 21
he was an environmental activist and i
talked to him basically i was like
look like this is what i care about and
he was like this is what i care about i
was like well what if we give both of
those things a bigger platform and we
actually try to run and do something
here and he's like you know what that's
great
and so it started with one person and
then within the next couple days we had
about four
and then the next week we had 10 and
then eventually got up to 50.
we're all under the age of 23 and
basically we were running because
we believed that things could actually
change and get better
and nobody else was going to do it and
so we had to
and that's really what we did and what
we've continued to do
and i don't know you know that we've
inspired people i just know that we're
doing what we believe
is right and what we believe somebody
needs to do
and we're seeing a lot of support of
people that believe exactly what we
believe and i have just been waiting for
somebody to come out and say it because
they believed it for so long but nobody
has been willing to speak
truth to power and actually come out and
say
what they believe and fight for it and
so that's kind of what's propelled us so
far
i think yeah it's a it's a
very relatable story on several levels i
agree with you that startups have been
uh hindered by the the fact that we've
just put so much
on small businesses in terms of uh
benefits healthcare like i mean i've run
companies and it's true when you make
that transition where
you are providing full-on benefits to
folks and people are making
multi-year commitments to you it's a lot
of pressure
as a company and right now we made it so
that that pressure breaks a lot of
startups to your point uh what were the
startups you were involved with uh you
know i remember the one but i want you
to speak to it a little bit so people
get a sense of
what brought you here yeah so the very
first one that i started right out of
college i had about three thousand
dollars in my pocket
that i had made from odd jobs working in
the summer on that on the drive
and it was essentially it was catching
international suppliers
trying to screw over family-owned
businesses and american businesses here
that were selling natural products the
second company really focused on kind of
the hemp and cbd
industries which are booming brand new
industries
but have zero regulation nobody's
actually looking out for other people or
trying to hold others accountable
and so that was really what i was doing
and i kind of feel like it's a good
transition especially to politics
because that's what congressional
representatives are supposed to do they
are supposed to hold people
who try to take care advantage of those
in their community accountable
and stop them yeah there's a
well there's a lot of that going on
unfortunately which brings us to your
opponent
who has like this backstory that i'm
very i could muster be confused by so
it's like okay i get ted yoho
he's been there for a long time he's
like a you know rich businessman lawyer
type
um and then but your opponent is not ted
your opponent
is his former employee
of some kind who worked in like a
communications
uh capacity is that right it's a little
fuzzy for me it's
very well here's the thing is it's very
fuzzy because it keeps
changing like every other day
so here's what we know we actually we
went and looked into this person because
you know in what i do is i essentially
you know try to look through marketing
and bs and try to see what is real what
is not
and be able to actually know um and so
we started looking into this person
and the very first thing i said the
first commercial i ever saw her was she
goes i grew up on a cattle ranch
in colorado and obama bankrupted me and
i was homeless
and i was like you know that's an
incredible story i wonder if any part of
the incredible
literally unbelievable it's amazing like
you i l like i don't know who you are
but like you got me like i am ready for
this story like i want to know about it
and so i looked into it and i couldn't
find the cattle ranch
like the first most simple thing is i
grew up on a cattle ridge and i couldn't
find it anywhere no property records
nothing and so like we spent weeks
looking for this thing
and then we finally threw it out on
twitter and we're like all right
internet go find this because we can't
find it and whatever you find
use the hashtag hashtag where's the
cattle ranch and tell us what you find
and they found so many things but they
couldn't find a cattle ranch
it was insane and so we eventually found
a piece of land
that was apparently bought by her mom at
one point but there were no buildings on
it
they never lived there so it was not a
cattle ranch on top of that they took
seven different loans out over 12 years
they had 350 thousand dollars in debt
and eventually they were foreclosed on
but it was not because of
obama it was because she went on a 108
day cruise that cost
30 grand across the world and she
literally
caused her family to lose their piece of
land on top of that it was right after
she graduated from college
and so she literally transitioned out of
college housing to an apartment
hotel and then joined ted yoho staff but
she said that because she had lived in a
hotel she was quote homeless
and she said the hotel was so bad that
she called it quote a crack house
so literally everything about her was
completely fake
and this was before she even got into
politics and so right at that moment we
knew that
something like there had to be things
that had happened because this is not a
story that most people have ever
experienced or seen and so it was
incredible for us she was his chief of
staff
she was 24 years old and about a year in
she was fired by ted yoho
but he refused to say why and she was
actually just
she was demoted and shipped back to
gainesville florida when she got there
the entire staff in washington was
purged and she set up a consulting firm
while still on his payroll and started
receiving more money
while doing this than she was as a chief
of staff for a sitting congressional
official
and also her husband's lawn mowing
company started to receive money as well
um and he still refuses to endorse her
so we realized something very shady and
sketchy was going on
and nobody still knew what the incident
was that led to her being fired and so
this is who we're running against
somebody who's made up their entire life
story
everything about themselves and it's
just it's insane and nobody has
ever looked into it well
you know unfortunately a lot of local
journalism
has uh withered and died and so not that
many people are digging in
all the source documents they have it
they've just refused to actually look
into it
yeah it's it's a tough time for
congressional candidates who are trying
to get a spotlight i've i've
seen this with some of the humanity
forward candidates including
you and this is a republican leaning
district
that seems like it could flip it's
interesting because ted's been there for
a while
um his uh your opponent um
i think many people just assume that
she'd just sort of sleepwalk into the
seat
even though as soon as you start
scrutinizing at any degree you're like
wait a minute this person is
like why is this person like the the
primitive favorite the republican
nominee to
to be a member of congress uh and you
are
uh you know to me like right on time
like if if you can get the support and
visibility you need
uh you would be such a fun
transformative
figure in congress uh we would have
implemented it would be
fun well we when we see the
i mean we see eye to eye on many issues
um one of the things that i'm passionate
about right now is
championing cash relief during this
pandemic and universal basic income
longer term but first things first just
cash relief
like where are you on trying to get
money into the hands of people
after we get you into congress january
2021
well i i i think i've tweeted about this
quite a few times but my first response
is basically any stimulus package that
anybody wants to put out if it doesn't
have cash relief at like
a thousand or two thousand dollars for
people that it should be dead on arrival
it shouldn't even be taken seriously and
it should honestly be retroactive
based on how much we should have been
getting for the last seven eight months
and so for me unless it has those
provisions i'm sorry but there is
literally no reason to vote for it
well hopefully we can get some energy
and resources your direction
to save us from your opponent as member
of congress
and you as member of congress would
would be a blast
uh where would people go to get behind
you to support you to find out more
about you and your campaign
the biggest place uh obviously is our
website which would be for the many
not just me.com and that would be the
best place
our twitter and social media is ac for
congress 2020
we also have an email list and different
things but you know we just dropped a
jobs plan
that would essentially bring about 9 000
jobs to our district and it takes all of
our big
ideas like high-speed rail and broadband
internet
and all of these different like small
business incubators
and actually makes it for our area
because we have these big ideas but if
we're not able to actually
create a vision that people can get
behind and actually see it in their
daily lives
then we're not doing anything that's you
know going to be actually substantial
and so that was a big thing for us is we
created this there's even
we even created a map where you could
scroll in and see different locations
and different things that would be
happening in our district
if we were to get into elected to office
and so for me that's what i'm focused on
i'm not focused on a 24-hour news cycle
like what's the most ridiculous thing
that you can make up and like
try to get people to care about it's
about people and it's about what we can
actually accomplish and
you know make our lives better because
that's what
we make our lives better amen adam amen
uh so so pumped for your race so pumped
for you to become uh the newest member
of congress
out of florida's third district uh adam
thank you for taking on this challenge
thank you for running
uh it's been a joy to support you and
your campaign
uh yeah let's just keep fighting keep
fighting and the the gap between you and
your opponent is very very wide
it's fun you know we've had a lot of
honestly most people don't have fun when
they run congressional campaigns like
they get to a point and they're just
you know it's just not fun anymore and
we have had so much fun
literally the last two days because my
birthday was two days ago literally the
last two days have just been phenomenal
and like i have not stopped
laughing pretty much for any point of
them and it's just
you gotta have fun you gotta love what
you're doing and you have to actually
care about people
and if you're grounded in that you're
gonna do okay we'll be with you every
step of the way adam uh really excited
for you and your race
thank you so much thank you for
listening in i hope you enjoyed this
conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you